[Music]
in justified attack news I love those
submitted by Shimon beli
a woman stabbed her boyfriend after
finding him naked with her I cracked my
lower back with her 12 year-old daughter
no you're supposed to say Donna
screaming with her 12 year old oh my god
she was a daughter consenting that's
[ __ ] up be too young to even
understand Oh questions know when you're
12 you know what son taking a nap or are
they napping in a very bad way he was
doing it with her yes did the daughter
want it though oh no cuz it's very bad
but sometimes they could want it too
it's still bad if they do a lot of older
men's hell younger girls like oh I'd
like you cuz you're so mature for your
age and that makes the girl feel like I
am mature and that girl is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to be around to her other friends
cuz they're like you gotta stop immature
yeah [ __ ] you the same as us oh yeah
what but yeah like that's my read it's a
memory that he has I say repress of a
certain girl yeah I read somewhere like
that's how they groom young girls and
they make them feel like they're like
this mature don't like me yeah he likes
because I'm so mature but it's really
like no dude he's gross if you still
have a world history test you're not
mature what it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you have a scantron in your backpack
your good PE clothes for an hour a day
you're not mature or the guy's [ __ ]
maturity level is so low yeah yeah so
this takes place in Cleveland Ohio
Cleveland OH Cleveland rocks so what
they're reporting is that around 2:30 in
the morning
police went to this home after this
woman started stabbing so this woman ran
outside screamed for people to call the
cops saying that
you know she's stabbed her boyfriend so
she she tells the police that would
happen was she was heading to her
bedroom when she noticed that her
boyfriend her 31 year old boyfriend was
naked on top of her daughter her 12 year
old daughter so she was they happy to
get in the home when she was home oh
that's crazy but that's when she a lot
of stuff happens when people are
sleeping yeah that's when she grabbed
her pocket knife and stabbed the dude
five times in his chest and once in the
back of his head
oh [ __ ] I wish it was a bigger knife
like a kitchen knife though we've been
[ __ ] amazing so the boyfriend is
saying that the mom thought that the
daughter had feelings for the boyfriend
and that's why she attacked him and then
the girl the daughter was saying that
the man went into her room and then took
off her pants took his clothes and said
this is what it's like in the real world
when you have a boyfriend and he's
sexually assaulted her oh dude that is
hella specific for that kid to lie yeah
some other [ __ ] things rapists say
before they do it is so creepy they
gotta like justify in their mind somehow
they're like this is a science project
let me introduce you to what it's like
to be a adult but I can't make it sound
normal to cancers there's people saying
like it's so juvenile because like
there's some people that say this is
like a secret time that adults have with
kids like you're not supposed to tell
anyone because it's secret was like two
adults over 20 people love each other a
lot
anatomy you're a base
let's neutralize each other creep that's
so weird look for the mondo first
cabinet
it was a bigger knife though I know I
was reading this like are you like yeah
like dating yeah right like she come on
like when you're dating a [ __ ] weirdo
don't you have some type of like maybe
he's not the right guy really like if
they go out on dates and he's always
facing like the kids playpen like if
you're always trying to find that seat
this guy I don't think it that ah yeah
oh really I don't think it's that
obvious because I mean pedophiles know
how to hide their [ __ ] [ __ ] hiding
pedophiles and there are there are
shitty parents to remember that honey
boo boo girl her her mom is dating like
a sex offender that has whatever would
minors and she's like no I'm not gonna
break up with him even though she has
kids in their house that's why they
pulled the TV show and everything or so
jealous
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean some people so honey
Boo Boo's mom looks like do you guys
remember spawn the fat clown yeah it
looks like there's a fat clown guy yeah
that's what honey Boo Boo's mom looks
like venom even after she lost thought I
wait don't wait well she lost his [ __ ]
already honey Boo Boo's mom looks like
Jabba the Hutt with girl hair yeah it's
a Java hut the hut with a blonde wig on
yeah she lost a lot of ways oh she's
actually pretty how the [ __ ] did she get
like 10 years younger so you just lost
it I haven't I didn't see her like this
because I think she got a lot of those
skin reductions she looks like six chins
holy look at this picture then look up
clown from spawn yo she's actually not
bad-looking yeah she looks great on the
right looks a lot prettier how does she
get younger
is it gastric bypass she did cuz that's
insane people do look younger after lose
weight yeah looks more you black magic
that's insane dude is she super fish you
can actually get pretty hot yeah she
used Wicca
newts eyes see right there she looks
like this guy worried they could see it
from a distance you know
yeah that's what she reminded John
Leguizamo yep she played that character
yeah this time yes yeah who's that John
Leguizamo you and Athena and you do not
know John Leguizamo she was really
popular he's an amazing actor yeah he
also paid Luigi in the Mario movie oh
yeah oh I forgot that you guys like
Antonio Banderas where's he been Antonio
Banderas is interesting because he was
somebody that was very popular among the
ladies and he always played Antonio
Banderas mr. hello sexy guy crazy man
and Puss in Boots yeah and I think that
was his like last and I think like his
niche disappeared because nobody wanted
to see that guy anymore the Latin Lover
and he tried to expand out of it and it
didn't work
now it's salt Bay yeah which lasted like
two we've got Latin and like that's that
kind of guy yeah yeah it's the hair he
likes to wear leather I actually follow
that dude on Instagram I love it me too
I want to actually want to eat his food
he's actual pretty good at boxing yeah
do bright yeah really yeah and it rains
a lot
yes believe that in the the the the peak
of his salt Bay meme Lord dumb I was in
Dubai
and I was like dude let's go to your
restaurant and nobody wanted to go why
it's a [ __ ] dog because his
restaurant sucks or what no because
they're like oh no can we just go
bowling I'm like we're in Dubai and you
[ __ ] want to go bowling
you know with us you have one of the
most famous restaurant yes celebrities
go there and he's like making like
tomahawk Wagyu steaks and my clarified
butter I'm like dude can I what though
and that is why you have to travel with
the right people this mom should have
had his knife skills oh yeah
and then she could have really
obliterated this [ __ ] I want to buy
that knife with the blue handle that yes
it looks like pretty cheap knife buy
these are shockingly well anyways back
to this sad story it was reported that
the woman and her daughter suffered
lacerations to their hands during the
struggle so what the he did to fight
back you just threw him off and then got
out of the house what he did was he
grabbed the woman by the neck threw her
against the wall and then later kicked
on the front door as she pushed him
outside and then they did he run
I guess I would follow travel bloggers
did you know he was arrested she stayed
at the house who arrived Connie's gonna
get bucks it's a small knife so I didn't
really hurt him that much me out of the
pocket knife he thinks only just
switches over a little red one or like a
big - [ __ ] right there she's just the
[ __ ] the power of a [ __ ] mom dude
she don't give up look I love wood
mulberry syndrome comes out that shit's
crazy like that's the protective mom
that's insane
can you imagine Gio like that mm-hmm she
was a [ __ ] big-ass [ __ ] she would
[ __ ] break this [ __ ] D ugh dude
it's pretty strong too I would just say
one thought well not sauce like I would
like if someone broke into your house
and threatened tyka oh it's behind dude
you went to the wrong home just start
your fee no services now I feel like
bars gonna grab the legs she was gonna
forth like grab my hands and they just
Rev him in half what if a robber came
into your house right and he looks at
stuff you know this house I just like
the door opens up in the bits then
they're in their bare stuff just soaked
you with their claws and they're all
fuzzy love it you know that happened to
thou one big guy that played the Russian
guy on yes yes yeah yeah what's the
story
no some some guys robbed the house they
burglarized the house the white yeah and
then they realized who the husband was
and they saw a picture
it was either out of fear or respect or
cuz they were fans but they just dropped
everything apologize invoices I will
break you on rocky you know the guy that
plays the Russian
rocky for big-ass russian dude he's like
God like six for something you've never
seen Rocky I'll make you never do the
rocky stuff longer don't flunk no that
was it dad you're right and what's the
name of the [ __ ] character Russian
boxing or something Ivan Drago I must
break you I will break you yeah also
broken his house tied up his wife and
kids just wife they saw his photo on the
mantle didn't they're like oh [ __ ] is
this his place and then Diego and
tighter and then said sorry and he left
I want people to fear me or and/or
respect me you know that be sick Rocky
is the worst depiction of actual boxing
ever but it was so exciting you don't
ever get hit in the face
eighty times in five seconds you know
it's a pretty intense I think also one
remember I told you guys when rocky or
Stallone told him to punch him for real
and he had to go to the hospital and the
doctors like you like your your injuries
are equivalent to getting hit by a truck
yeah the fights in Rocky they just take
hits cuz they wanted to have like the
realism to it you're pretty down the
Apollo character oh yeah I could be
Jordan Michael B Jordan knocked out yeah
he knocked him out
yes I'm saying he knocked his ass out he
goes it's like he had that was his
stipulation like you got to get knocked
out I have a good deal C pleasure seeing
people get knocked out I think everyone
knows my favorite one is looking to get
knocked out and for some reason there's
stiffest buck that's how you know you're
[ __ ] I saw this video of a there's
this kid oh he's dead talk about these
[ __ ] dead there's this video this kid
trying to fight an old man I don't know
where the [ __ ] he was like I don't know
where it was was kid trying to find an
old man and everyone's like leave alone
like no one but no one's helping and I'm
like yup I'm trying to fight this old
man no one did [ __ ] and this guy walks
by with this shopping bag and waits for
the kid to turn around he's [ __ ]
popped him and he fell hit his
no the the metal bench and then everyone
started laughing I do of this old
grandpa who you could clearly tell you
the professional boxer on the pier yeah
he swung he went yeah yeah hey guys
thanks for watching the last episode did
you love it I know you did but guess
what you can also follow us on our
personal social media accounts with the
links in the description box below so go
follow all of us now to watch more
videos check them out up there
[Music]